[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
pas de la villa
alors là oui ça va
ces femmes et magie de ce spectacle sur
le parisien
bravo c'est réussi pour la première
connard de buffy
tu aimes bien d'un fumigène il dit
bonjour en faisant sa
spéciale d'avis très spécial on l'a vu
il faut que tu vois quelqu'un
fait qu'il voit un psy mois plusieurs
d'entre eux vérifient doit être caché
quelque part à bord ça fait plaisir
la viande est telle qu'elle se fait dix
ans qu'on s'est pas vu on n'a pas changé
et surtout moi non je n'ai pas changé
mais pas fin
au secteur tous trouvent séduisant
digérer un tas marché que les filles
soient non c'est très bien un
nantais animateurs numéro un des
français ouais bah ça va être vachement
juste que tu veux alors voilà ça a
changé ma vie il vous plait michel cymes
[Musique]
j'ai pas sentir un enthousiasme
on va commencer
à manali dalle trac il est planqué
quelques pâles il pas enfermer dans les
chiottes et tracker bras alors ouais bah
non mine de rien nations qui sont rien
que ça mais pas du tout vous le prenez
pour un robot va s'installer tout c'est
un être humain c'est vrai il a un coeur
vous savez quoi c'est le warm up
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le principe du warm up c'est de
regarder les meilleurs moments de la
semaine dernière
alors visite privée je suis sûr que vous
savez pas que c'est le titre d'un film
porno etc tabatha cash
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'après vous ce
pirae les audiences vous êtes parmi ceux
qui résistaient bien avec frédéric lopez
après c'est un peu moins bien il ya plus
de chroniqueurs que le téléspectateur
exalte les rues je sais que j'ai rappel
mais répondant es vous êtes une sacré
bon tournoi quand j'ai vu ça la première
fois j'ai pensé que c'est une pub pour
une lessive
je me suis dit quand on l'a vu très
blanc way that as peur qu'à noël et 5
nagui sur la photo
mais franchement tu es fan elle est
merveilleuse la reine d'angleterre mais
franchement là n'a pas pris position sur
les briques site elle sait à quoi font
de grandes loges mais c'est à être
renier demande cet exercice particulier
du pouvoirs d'incarnés plutôt que de
dire au fond je crois en la monarchie
comme les catholiques romains radi je
passe sur le jeu super se dit que je
verrai pas ça de mon vivant et après
tout tant mieux parce que mais les pays
d'europe qui ont une monarchie vivent en
monarchie républicaine nous on vit dans
une république monarchique on a donné
plus de pouvoir le président que n'en
avait louis xiv jurés vous de tout faire
pour remettre le roi sur le trône ah non
faut pas exagérer un
merde ah non je suis hyper déçu non mais
fou mais ça veut dire quoi tout faire
tout je suis pas là ce que vous venez de
faire déjà c'est bien je veux bien là
des gens qui vous regardent oui moi je
veux bien défendre son idée oui encore
non franchement
ça va valoir trop dans merde
l'autre prénom de louis saez était
dieudonné vrai ou faux
oui oui
[Applaudissements]
à à la bataille de waterloo les anglais
chanté du cabanon
à se soumettre ou se démettre était la
devise du club gay dans lequel traînait
souvent gambetta
des femmes ah non je veux ce débat
gvt est pas
comme on le dit dans deux heures dans le
cas c'est pas secret s'est dit ce que
veut dire un truc simplement c'est que
c'était le premier film que jamais été
tourné en antarctique elle fut films de
fiction et que pierre niney mois on a
été déposée un jour sur une banquise
l'équipe est partie parce qu'on veut
faire un plan drones celui qu'on vient
de voir et voilà on a été dans
l'immensité absolue sans la moindre
personne en vue pierre et moi on pouvait
pas bouger parce qu'il fallait pas faire
de traces sur la banquise est écrasé par
cette beauté incroyable et du coup c'est
tellement étrange que on s'y raccrocher
une conversation complètement
superficiel et on a commencé à parler du
prix au mètre carré des appartements
pareil
pendant une heure il
est clair c'est caché au pôle sud vous
n'avez pas vu comme ça c'est ça qui est
génial c'est que réussir à survivre même
dans une base au pôle sud c'est quand
même très très difficile il faut être
très organisé ouais dans l'eure est
clair donc pas s'égarer vraie question
est un défi la vraie question c'est
est-ce qu hitler est mort ou non dans
son bunker en 45 c'est une question qui
pourrait éventuellement être discuté à
mon avis il est mort dans son bunker
c'est les russes qui sont arrivés là on
n'a jamais su en fait jean marc tout le
problème c'est quand on n'a pas d'aidé
éléments comme le comme alexandre le
grand oui on n'a jamais retrouvé le
corps d'alexandre en avant l'étendue
qu'on avait trouvé le crâne d'hitler
mais je crois que les russes avaient
montré qu'ils étaient faux enfin bon ça
dans le métier se soit retrouvé en au
pôle sud femmes paraissent d'abord
j'ai souvent ressenti en tant qu'acteur
le sentiment d'être un usurpateur qui va
être découvert dans sa vacuité j'ai
totalement des évidences encore je suis
un usurpateur mais finalement pas pire
qu'un autre voire même moins que l'autre
con corgnac
ça je les dis la semaine
pas dit non plus il c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai
plus je vieillis plus je baise c'est
génial d'être acteur je
vous le dit pas ça
[Musique]
la mer
brown à la récré personne ne veut jouer
à chat bisous avec lui
et
personne ne veut jouer à chat bisous un
personne ne vous embrasser parce que
vous êtes albinos est ce que vous avez
trouvé quelqu'un aujourd'hui n'en tôt
pour jouer à chat bisous
oui
oui ou non joker n'emballait pas de
guerre ici
y'a personne qui veut jouer affirmé je
ne joue plus à sa bise ou en fait mieux
qu'un bon d'accord
un autre truc vous nous expliquerez
alors je vous montrais des plaques de
village vous allez me dire si ça existe
ou pas lambert attention on se concentre
bourré oui ça existe et dans le
loir-et-cher braves
ont continué mon cul oui oui elle
célèbre jacques prévost on continue
oui c'est possible
le pas la grande que existe
on continue
oui ça existe pourtant c'est dans le
cantal d'honneur
on me dit alors il ya des tirs de la
grande que n'existe pas ça n'existe pas
en village ce que vous dites dans le
bouquin c'est qu'il ya une théorie qui
dit que voilà les anglais auraient pris
le corps de napoléon à sainte-hélène où
lemaitre a vite mis dans le pétrin
westminster et le remplacer par ge et le
maître d'hôtel de napoléon à sainte
élisabeth chip rihanna qui était un
corse qui nous ressemblait vaguement
musc et écorces et donc on aurait on
aurait irrité finalement à paris de tuer
moi je dit la police je suis convaincu
on va il ya très très peu d'éléments
pour le guen et quelques éminents quand
on a enterré napoli en 1821 on a fait un
procès verbal quand on l'a déterré en
1136 on a refait un procès verbal on est
je sais bien on a opéré avec ses bottes
on rouvre le cercueil on voit les bottes
à conan non non on l'a enterré avec les
décorations dans un sens ça sert à
cesser les retraites en déclarant qu'ils
voient l'acno mais en tout ont
recommandé texte je ferai mes stéphane
bern s'amuserait généraux wolton bon
j'étais dominique de villepin était
premier ministre je dis bah écoutez
monsieur rémy ouvrant le cercueil sauf
qu'à sept cercueils en différant marbre
bois et ses effectifs et donc une
diminution décide de vérifier qu'il est
dedans ça va savoir dans le monde entier
parce qu'on va fermer le dôme des
invalides
on va dire ben voilà pendant quelques
jours on doit fermer avaient une pour
vérifier si napoléon est dedans sauf que
les touristes du monde entier qui se
précipitent aux invalides pour aller se
recueillir devant le tombeau de napoléon
vous dira boyard
mais jamais on n'a plus beaucoup de
touristes
alors fauves on retrouve dans le jury de
danse avec les stars à partir du 15
octobre alors parmi les candidats il ya
beaucoup d'animateurs télé il ya julien
lepers cia valérie damidot il ya olivier
minne ya karine ferri se la ferme
célébrités d'un an
est ce que quelqu'un va tenter importés
avec valérie damidot
et quand je pense qu'on peut être étonné
après
qui s'y colle c'est christian millette
skyrock [ __ ] bravo la
montagne mon bébé comment ça va oh qu'il
est mignon celui là c'est bien c'est de
la bonne télévision a l'impression que
ça s'apprend bien eu petit débrief des
twittos d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à
commenter l'émission en direct hashtag
slt on élira la semaine prochaine alors
je voudrais commencer déjà par un petit
mea culpa voilà la semaine dernière
j'avais dit que nous répondrions à la
question pourquoi kim kardashian est
elle toujours habillé en [ __ ] et a suivi
ce message totalement justifiée d'agnès
langlois qui nous dit tom n'est pas
obligé de dire que kardashian
s'habillant put pourquoi toujours
rabaissés les nanas les insultes et
voilà je m'en excuse le plus platement
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de diffuser
les photos de kim kardashian qui la met
le plus en valeur et qui la dénigrent
pas voilà
le trial d'une pu nord une deuxième
peut-être voilà une dernière pour
terminer voilà donc vraiment autant pour
moi comme quoi des fois il ya des
méprises sur les gens
la semaine dernière thierry vous avez
fait le jeu des villages mais nos
invités et vous nous avez montré un peu
les les villages de france est un petit
jeu on est montré mon cul anus etc il ya
souidi selma sur twitter qui nous a
signalé que vous en aviez oublié une on
le découvre voilà c'est plus de villes
et pour ma part il y en a une petite de
ma collection personnelle c'est la
commune de nadine morano voilà
comme un jab il ya jurisprudence
maintenant les jurisprudences
et une pluie pour pour terminer la
semaine dernière l'une des invités ici
c'était fauve hautot qui a mûri dans
danse avec les stars et vous êtes moquer
d'une des candidats de danse avec les
stars valérie damidot ont regardé et m'a
fait une vidéo tenez ça tout seul
comme ça mon petit chéri tu te dis que
personne ne va pouvoir réussir à porter
je dis non je suis trop grosse trop
lourde pas du tout excuse-moi maire
christian christian teinturier sa porte
et je suis pas londres
une vrai qu il ne devrait plus on en est
voilà une forme de question donc quand
je vais revenir sur un surtout plateau
anti thierry pourtant mon bouquin ça on
fera le porter tous les deux j'étais
tellement rien texto en me traitant de
ghislain souza gentil ville j'ai pas
entendu ça depuis maman et ben vous avez
surprise ce soir ça démarre danse avec
les stars vous allez être étonnés ah
ouais ah oui d'un coup tu viens quand tu
veux valérie avec l'eau mais quitte à
porter
bon c'est la formule
fonctionne ans la fin du match je pense
voilà
enfin
[Musique]
c'est ma
vie
ce à l'intérieur
c'était bienvenue dans votre retour du
samedi soir bonsoir très heureux de vous
retrouver sur céline désormais pour dix
ans taper
premier qui a invité ce soir le docteur
qui fait mourir de rire messieurs si mr
première terrienne invité ce soir notre
tt ou de la semaine c'est logique vu
qu'elle chante la chanson lions
[Musique]
autre terian que ce soir celui qui a été
remplacé par john stumme comme meilleur
ami de jean dujardin bruno salomone
ont fait d'eux peut-être pas le plus
grand footballeur de l'histoire mais
sans doute le plus beau david ginola
impeccable bilan 2010 est et la battle
des idées ce soir alimentation du poison
dans nos assiettes avec l'auteur du best
seller it gilles artigues au
voilà l'émission s'appelle santana le
groupe et gréement de fortune et le
hashtag
cst
[Musique]
et maintenant
voici mon cdd comme villa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
atterrir tout va bien bon ben je
recherche toujours belle fille très très
beau plateau ce soir thierry deux
invités très drôle et puis bruno
salomone aussi
non honneur aux dames à une lettre près
le portait le prénom d'une voiture mais
c'est sans regret car elle est beaucoup
mieux carrossée c'est lyon
alors les autres votre vrai nom c'est
wanda maria ribeiro furtado tavares de
vasconcelos
c'est à n'y avait rien ces portugais en
français ça veut dire le petit castor
qui construit le barrage vous
êtes de retour avec la tournée star 80
lits ou alors on peut se moquer des
stars des années 80 enfin mine de rien
ils ont coiffé 2 stade de france des
énigmes toute la france vont en revanche
c'est le seul concert ou quand le public
crie une autre le mec refait la même
chanson
non mais c'est vrai que les stars des
années 80 c'est ça fait plaisir à tout
le monde tout le monde ans s'amusent
dans les chansons par coeur le truc
c'est que dans les stars des années 80
pour moi ya deux catégories il ya ceux
qui acceptent de vieillir et puis à les
autres avec plastic bertrand il n'a
jamais aussi bien porté son nom
qu'aujourd'hui mais qu'il est tendue on
dirait une tente quechua quoi c'est à
lui et julie piétri quand le grand jour
arrivera qu'on souhaite plus loin
possible sa vespa le cimetière c'est la
poubelle jaune 1 c
[Applaudissements]
elle le sait lui ou elle et côtoie au
quotidien revient façon il ya deux stars
qui cartonne en ce moment ses stars 80
et star wars alors dans là on utilise
les mêmes ficelles depuis 40 ans
toujours à coups d'effets spéciaux de
mecs qui respire mal piloté star wars
[Applaudissements]
notre deuxième invité il est premier au
classement des animateurs préférés des
français s'il avait su ça il se serait
pas fait chier à faire 12 ans d'études
c'est michel cymes
alors michel houel à la leçon soir pour
aura attiré son examen de la prostate ah
je couds va bien non pour la promo de
son dernier lecteur d'ailleurs un petit
lac erie vous connaissez le point commun
entre un examen de la prostate et et les
impôts passe à ce jour le dernier tiers
le plus difficile
michel vous venez pour votre dernier
livre les arnaques de la médecine alors
dans votre livre on apprend plein de
trucs on apprend par exemple que le
docteur freud préconise l usage de la
cocaïne voiliers de série c médicale à
la base
de ce que vous pouvez dire à la police
michel c'est un carton la librairie son
dernier livre il en a vendu 300 mille
exemplaires ça s'appelait vivait mieux
et plus longtemps alors dans vos
conseils pour vivre mieux vous dites que
je vous cite que dans la vie il faut
s'éclater très bonne nouvelle des chats
bien suivi les conseils du national
michels et ça cartonne à la télé il a
fait onze prime avec adriana karembeu ça
s'appelait le pouvoir extraordinaire du
corps humain et le pouvoir
extraordinaire du corps de michel c'est
de ne pas partir en érection alors
qu'ils passent h 24 avec un man
[Applaudissements]
en surpoids
notre dernière invitée est très très
drôle et lui c'est son métier et il est
beaucoup moins cher de l'heure que
michel cymes c'est bruno salomone
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou pas une brute ou quand vous
voyez que notre métier est galvaudé
comme ça pas des gens comme michel cymes
venez on ouvre un cabinet jeu si on
s'est dit ce qu'est une souris on peut
finir spasfon ces deux fois contre vous
michel serres en gros ça q pour vous
bruno votre spectacle y revient au
théâtre montparnasse ça s'appelle
euphorique alors nouveau toit même chose
quand vous jouez quarante trois
personnages en 1h30 s'échapperait aussi
plein de gérance à sainte-anne on
appelle ça un lundi ouais
et jetons à nous imiter chewbacca dans
votre spectacle assez face à une tâche
est un peu court de petits riffs et dark
vador mais c'est vrai avec sa bouche
et puis
si vous êtes de retour dans brice de
nice 3 qui arrive bientôt vous reprenez
votre rôle d'igor d'hossegor l'or joue
avec en tyrie de paris michel de la
rochelle lio de saint malo et le public
des assedic
une bonne nouvelle ils sont en vie vous
auriez pu être chez michel drucker donc
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
posez
faudra vous y mettre un jour tu irais je
place à l'émission jean mois lio lyon
pour le concert de stars 83 que la
production réserve encore quelques
artistes qui n'ont pas mis sur la fiche
du coup ça va compléter la programmation
ça dépend du tribunal pour jean luc
lahaye
michel cymes nagui a dit de vous michel
il adore les touches eric tôt alors sans
tomber dans la vulgarité mais pour
donner une image vous êtes plutôt le
train ou le tunnel vous
nagui il adore aussi parce qu'en fait il
me dénonce dans la presse mais c'est lui
qui me les réclament
alors pour terminer bruno salomone dans
votre spectacle ya quarante trois
personnages vous déplacer d'un homme à
une femme en un claquement de doigts
vous êtes plus rapide qu amanda lear
a bâti en même temps
voilà
[Musique]
m
et maintenant mesdames messieurs on
passe à neutre grand invité d'honneur
michel cymes re bonsoir
alors jamais le magazine de la santé et
allô docteurs et les pouvoirs
extraordinaires du corps humain sur
france télévisions vous avez une
chronique tous les matins sur rtl vous
écrivez des livres on va parler du
dernier vous préparez un documentaire
pour france 2 sur les médecins nazis
dans les camps d'extermination
j'imagine quand on est médecin vous
trouver facilement des produits qui
donnent de l'énergie non je vois où vous
voulez en venir mais non je ne prend
absolument rien après tu changes même
pour essayer pour voir ce que c'est je
peux vous dire que j'ai déjà essayé un
joint ouais pour voir ce que ça a donné
je me suis allongé sur le lit il y avait
le papier peint qui bougeait donc je me
suis dit j'arrête et c'est tout je n'ai
rien touché d'autres
[Musique]
c'est son sample chaque fois qu'il vient
il est là
et
voilà à part ça bien sûr vous êtes
toujours toubib vous avez choisi le seul
métier au monde où on peut dire à une
femme déshabillez vous soi même la
connaître alors
je veux pas dire trop ma spécialité pour
pâques les gens veulent venir me voir
l'hôpital mais j'ai une spécialité qui
touchent plutôt la tête et le cou donc
j'ai pas la chance de demander aux
patients de se déshabiller bien qu'il me
soit arrivé une fois qu'une femme se met
torse nu pour jouer examine la partie
haute du visage mais
il a fallu que je demande de travail et
puis j'ai eu du mal à l'expliquer à
l'infirmière qui rentrait par comme ça
dans le box avec une vraie spécialité
s'est soigné l'audience dans les
émissions de télé dit ça je dois dire
que chapeau fait une émission l'audience
explose j'ai toujours le présentateur
préféré des français
nagui est toujours derrière vous faites
gaffe quand même et est justement comme
je me méfie beaucoup quant à guy
derrière moi j'ai creusé l'écart à voile
a fait j'ai laissé un peu plus de
distance en bio troisième c'est stéphane
bern méfiez vous aussi oui mais il
faudra d'abord qu'ils passent par nagui
avant le match et d'en faire
[Applaudissements]
alors moi en tant qu'admin batian près
tous les français
j'ignore 72e j'ai essayé le toucher
rectal les blagues et tout ça marche pas
mais c'est peut-être proportionnelle à
l'âge j'ai mon âme au chant mais oui
mais j'aimerais bien être comme vous à
votre âge
non
[Applaudissements]
mon auto thierry savard
à la poulette
cadeau
bonsoir ça va mon lolo oui je suis
revenu remonté un peu l'ambiance te
donner deux trois conseils pour que ça
marche un peu plus déjà les invités j'ai
connu une époque on avait
ré de chars jane fonda bruce willis
ouais
là je débarque on a quoi une portugaise
un pneu
alors quercy marine le pen passe tu vas
voir des gros tournois
mais moins de trois bretons là dedans
on peut avoir un petit bout de son
sampler quand même
ah ah
[Musique]
nos agents va la vie ouais
alors on continue à michel cymes et la
promotion du livre de michel cymes
moment alors michel simon gerrans jdc
que je te passent moins je sais qu'avant
quand même non tu peux faire chier de
manière bien quand je le sens mais pas
par voilà à n'importe quoi n'a pas
n'importe qui alors oui je me souviens
des positions
priorité à la vanne vous êtes ici pour
votre nouveau livre michel cymes les
arnaques de la médecine j'imagine que
vous n'êtes pas mis sur les noms je me
suis permis sur la liste parce que je ne
suis pas du tout un charlatan moi
monsieur madame ardisson voilà il
nous a rassemblés dans ce livre les 50
plus grandes arnaques et erreurs
médicales de l'histoire il n'y a rien
sur les tarifs de sos médecins le
dimanche soir 95 euros dimanche soir
c'est très cher et en même temps vous
êtes content de les avoir parce que rien
d'autre alors vous dites dans votre
bouquin ne sert à rien de se laver le
sexe avec du pepsi tron après avoir fait
l'amour pour éviter d'attraper la
syphilis vous parler du livre de laurent
baffie
je reconnais pas ce que j'ai écrit c'est
que si tu lis aujourd'hui c'est plus
facile à soigner qu'à écrire je
n'interviens pas je veux dire la non je
ressens pas là
alors vous révéler dans ce livre que le
vibromasseur a été inventé pour soigner
l'hystérie féminine
parce que les toubibs en avait marre de
titiller manuellement le clitoris oui
parce qu'en fait c'est venu de ce qu'on
imaginait autour de l'hystérie hystérie
ça vient du thé russe à la matrix et à
avant qu'on connaisse bien le tome i on
pensait que l'utérus des femmes se
promenait dans l'organisme c'est à dire
que quand ça allait bien et est en bas
puis parfois il monte il passait dans
les poumons le tueur j'avais trouvé le
[ __ ] mois
c'est embêtant parce que justement à une
époque on s'est dit enfin c'est
hippocrate qui avait mis ça et puis ce
après lui qui pensait que toutes les
maladies des femmes notamment l'hystérie
venait d'un problème notamment sexuelles
et pouvait être guéri et traités par
l'orgasme et donc l'idée ça va être ça a
été pendant un moment de il appelait ça
la titrisation du clitoris à la
résidence est vrai par effectivement
leur en fallait savoir où ces thèmes et
à votre âge vous devriez le savoir faire
mal c'est embêtant
la minuterie c'est dur à trouver dans le
noir n'ont normalement dont je vous
donnerai des repères anatomiques fort
mais est effectivement les médecins
titille les le kit le clitoris de faire
jouer les femmes et alors bien sûr il y
avait aussi un massage vaginale est en
fait c'était tellement à la mode qu'il
en avait un peu marre parce que ça
devenait fatiguant on va pas parler ça
lasse il c'était fatigant et donc ils
ont il ya un médecin qui a inventé le
vibromasseur pour remplacer soulager le
médecin et parce que rené raconté que
cléopâtre prenez des rouleaux de papyrus
dans lesquels elle mettait des abeilles
ce qui fait que ce rouleau de papyrus
illégaux et qu'elle serait appliquée sur
le clitoris vous pensez que c'est vrai
alors je n'ai pas personnellement connu
à l'époque mais j'espère surtout que le
papier était assez solide alors on
continue il ya plein de trucs dans l'île
de cimaises freud par exemple considérer
que la cocaïne soigner tout et c'est ce
qu'il avait fait avec un de ses très
très bon ami qui était addict à la
morphine parce qu'il avait une grave
blessure dames 1 et effectivement à
l'époque on se disait que la cocaïne ça
soulageait de tous
d'un côté c'est pas faux ça soulage et
un peu de la dépression et tout parce
que quand vous prenez la cocaïne êtes
champion du monde vous décuplée vos
forces pour votre intérêt intelligence
et c est son pote qui avait inquiété
morphinomane parce qu'ils prenaient trop
de morphine pour ses douleurs il lui a
donné de la cocaïne ce qui a permis à
l'autre de d'arrêter
l'addiction à la morphine et finalement
il est mort d'une addiction à la cocaïne
alors vous raconter que bob marley qui
était rastafari donc les rastafaris se
soigne pas avec les médecines
traditionnelles il a eu un mélanome à
leur taille il est mort ben oui en fait
bob marley j'avais un fameux docteur
bagua qui s'occupait de lui qui lui
donnait des concoctions de l'herbe et
c'est pas forcément de la marijuana mais
d'autres pour le traiter en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que bob marley il
s'est fait mal en jouant au foot il a eu
un premier traumatisme sur le gros
orteil un crampon vouziers à crampons
rouillé au départ il il a traité ça
comme il a pu quelques années plus tard
il se reprend un coup sur l'orteil il
finit par consulter au bout d'un moment
un médecin à londres qui lui dit c'est
un mail à nos enfants amputés l'orteil
voir le pied et en fait chez les rastas
il faut garder l'intégrité du corps on
peut pas se faire amputer donc il a
refusé il a continué à se soigner mal il
a fini par se faire opérer
dans un hôpital on sait pas très bien ce
qu'il a fait mais c'était trop tard il
avait des métastases au cerveau
notamment et il s'est effondré lors d'un
footing et puis il avait trop de
métastases y demeure effectivement tu
sais tu meurs alors steve jobs c'est
pareil tiens le mais qui il a un toubib
qui lui dit un naturopathe qui lui
dit-on concerne du pancréas on va le
soigner avec des jus de carotte c'est ce
qui est intéressant aussi c'est qu'à
travers le portrait de deux types comme
steve jobs ce dont on peut pas imaginer
une seconde que ce soit un faible que
qu'ils soient d'arrêt qui sache pas
exactement ce qu'il faut faire pour
soigner sa maladie il a eu un cancer du
pancréas c'était une des formes assez
rare de cancer du pancréas qui annuel
soit cette forme du cancer balle sinon
je te le dis le cancer du pancréas en
trois mois mais là au moins celui là on
peut y lire et en fait il a tellement
attendu à cause de ce naturopathe ans
qui est dans lequel il croyait en jus de
carotte machin etc et de pommes il a pas
vrai il n'a pas voulu il a voulu c'est
bien je vais pas il a roulé à terroriser
voilà moi je suis jus de gingembre mois
+ janssen réponse adaptée au passage sur
les érections non ça c'est que les gens
n'ont
alors adolf hitler était végétarien il
ne buvait pas ne fumait pas en revanche
il y avait un mec c'est les docteurs
morel dont vous parlez dans votre
bouquin c'est très intéressant c'était
le maître piqueur du troisième reich il
lui faisait des injections toute la
journée alors il a injecté du multi
fleurs multicolores cet effet avec de
l'estomac de bulgares 1 avec des
bactéries issues de paysans bulgare
robuste et il y faisait des injections
hitler en permanence c'est à dire avant
un discours quand l'autre avait mal au
mans parce que en dehors d'un grand
psychopathe c'était un grand malade il
était il et il avait des maladies
partout où il est né
oui oui il avait fait un truc la
cryptorchidie il avait un micro pénis et
il avait un hip hop badia célibat dias
et comme bien que au lieu d'avoir le le
trou pour faire pipi devant
c'est votre cas il l'avait en dessous
donc voilà disputée sur les pompes et là
on va lire la pologne
alors il se faisait un jeté de le caudal
qui était un truc encore plus puissant
que l'héroïne ouais j'ai foncé et oui et
morel son médecin lui à lui injecter
alors parfois c'était rien c'était du
glucose du sucre et parfois c'était
aussi des stéroïdes donc ils étaient
dopés peut-être qu'avant ses discours
pour qu'il est ce ce côté complètement
hystérique lors des disques est assurée
et shooté aux stéroïdes à la bonne heure
et du pervitine kessé amphétamines c'est
ce que prennent les images il a dit en
gros c'est du cap d'agde ont quoi les
amphétamines il ya ces sont les soldats
allemands à qui on enfilait sur le front
pour pour qu'il soit complètement
euphorique qui sont plus le froid la
faim et c est en fait assez et à la
méthamphétamine qu'en fait tous ces mecs
là été défoncée tous et hitler en
particulier voilà il ya un truc que vous
racontez aussi je trouve extraordinaire
c'est qu'en afrique du sud il ya un mec
s'appelait goûteurs basse one lui alors
il voulait éliminer les noirs comme ça
j'aurais eu que des blancs en afrique du
sud dès lors ils avaient mis au point
une bactérie qui était disons fixé par
les peaux noires ce type faisait partie
d'un projet très secret qui consistait à
tout faire pour éliminer d'une part les
opposants et les leaders noirs et puis
d'autre part essayer d'éliminer aussi le
maximum de deux noirs finalement et donc
ils avaient inventé mais mais des trucs
mais complètement délirant il avait même
imaginé contaminé par le virus du sida
les prostituées du année ce bourg pour
que prostituée noire bien sûr pour que
les noirs qui venait soit contaminée ils
avaient tout imaginé et effectivement il
cherchait à mettre au point une bactérie
qui ne toucherait que les peaux noires
c'est fou et le plus fou c'est que ce
type exerce encore non parce que s'il a
été en fait c'était un cardiologue il a
été
jugée faute de preuves il a été relaxé
il a juste été condamné par le conseil
de l'ordre des médecins sud africain qui
lui a donné une sorte de blague ça
s'appelle tarmac de la médecine c'est
publié aux éditions du chêne j'ai écrit
ça avec une fille qui s'appelle emma ce
trac
[Musique]
et voilà
est ce que vous avez entendu parler de
la question sous serment non c'est ma
dernière idée la question sous serment
[Musique]
michel cymes
cette fameuse nuit vous étiez avec
karine lemarchand
particulièrement aimé chez tous les deux
voir bourrée
elle a essayé de coucher avec vous
est-ce que vous jure et michel cymes
qu'il ne s'est rien passé cette nuit-là
avec karine le marchand
je le jure sur la tête d'adriana
karembeu
là maintenant
ça difficile de vous reposer la question
il y avait répondu une fois pour toute
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs on
passe au conseil pourri du docteur cimex
[Musique]
d'al-qasim s quels conseils donner quand
on veut tomber dans le coma mais
métal et vous voulez que soient radiées
du conseil de l'ordre qua non mais je
peux pas en tant que médecin vous donner
des conseils pareil et quel conseil de
l'ue si on veut prendre du poids
s'habiller en noir
j'allais lui demander quel était son
régime préparait ouais non ben il faut
venger très gras très sucré
quels conseils donner si on veut avoir
les dents jaunes qui a fait de l'iphone
ont une chemise blanche
même quand celle voulu donner si on veut
perdre ses cheveux
car des vannes
pas de shampooing je me pisse dessus
quand même quelques enseignes données
docteur sur me sentir monde et de la
bouche
[Rires]
voir embrasser baptisons domaine
et si on va choper une hépatite c qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire abbas est infecté
avec une seringue qu'on trouve par terre
par exemple d'accord très bien il faut
surtout pas jeter de seringues propres
grade hier à si on veut faire une crise
cardiaque en faisant l'amour qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire docteur
ça dépend du partenaire thierry je pense
que
c'est bon c'est pas si je les ai ici
c'est que toi tu as un problème je pense
que si vous le faites à votre âge avec
une quinzaine de jeunes filles à la
suite il est possible que vous arriviez
pas la quinzième titre accor merci
docteur et quels conseils donneriez vous
si on veut surtout pas faire jouer une
femme va vous continuez
vivait quasiment pas de lait faisait si
mal
c'était la braderie se tait on se
retrouve sur terre après l'attaqué
[Musique]
dans la soirée d'hier soir était un
jeune de retour sur terre toujours en
compagnie de michel cymes
millau
bruno salomone
et nous accueillons notre thé auteurs
david ginola
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
david jeu-là bonsoir
ouah
[Musique]
non le monde
alors d'avis
après avoir mis le feu à tous les stades
de foot d'europe el magnifico est
devenue la nouvelle star de m6 en juin
dernier vous avez cartonné avec l'euro
et à partir du 25 octobre c'est vous qui
animerait la france a un incroyable
talent pourtant david vous revenez de
loin je parle pas de france bulgarie 93
non mais de votre arrêt cardiaque lé 19
mai dernier ce jour là vous avez frôlé
la mort vous êtes un miraculé david
ginola
david ginola
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes né à gaza dans le var le 25
janvier 1967 votre père travaillait à
l'usiné de torpilles de saint tropez
votre mère chez france télécom votre
premier ballon de foot vous l'avez eue
pour noël à l'âge de 2 ans à 5 ans vous
faites vos premiers dribbles et à 19 ans
vos premières passes
1 19 ans vous signer au sporting de
toulon ensuite j'ai le matra racing
brest à cette époque vous fait vos
débuts chez les bleus contre l'albanie
en oeuvre en 1990 la niche elle denisot
vous engage au psg pour trois cent mille
euros il a dit cela plus belle à faire
de ma vie c'est pas cher pour ginola
c'était pas cher en fait parce que
j'étais j'étais rendu libre par mon club
précédent le brest armorique et une
liquidation financière et donc ses
joueurs avaient été mis sur le marché
libre de tout de tout transfert donc
michel denisot va récupérer pour
pratiquement rien c'est au psg que j'ai
explosé il ya un but en particulier qui
restera dans toutes les mémoires c'est
le 18 mars 1993 c'est contre le real de
madrid on regarde mais à dix minutes du
coup de sifflet final le parc des
princes se dit que l' attente en valait
la peine
allo
et à
[Applaudissements]
moi j'étais dans les tribunes un quai en
q3 je vais au parc depuis que j'ai 17
ans et j'étais j'étais là c'était
c'était un grand moment de partage et
c'est vrai que là michel était dans les
tribunes et tu marques tu tournes à
rooney bent avait tout à fait d'ailleurs
c'est la lire là je suis en train de
tout faire si non mais c'est ce que ce
qu'on aime aussi voir dans le football
c'est des moments comme ça qui sont très
privilégié de partage de communion avec
le public et c'est vrai qu'à cette
époque là il y avait effectivement eu
une équipe à paris dans les années 90 et
là c'est le grand
[Musique]
je suis
cet automne mais c'est le bas fond par
les deux marées la 90e minute
vous avez parlé non c'est pas que je
n'aime pas en parler je sais que je vais
être très clair avec vous aujourd'hui
je suis un garçon qui est passé par
toutes les étapes et même la mort
aujourd'hui la vie je la vois j'en
parlais avec michel complètement
différemment je vais droit au but sur
tout mais vraiment revenir sur un
épisode comme ça où la semaine dernière
il y avait en france bulgarie où tous
les journalistes se sont empressés de
m'appeler pour me demander mon avis sur
le match bien mais je m'en fous mais je
m'en fous complet aujourd'hui je suis
présentateur sur m6 animateur
d'émissions de divertissement je me
donne à 100% dans mon nouveau métier
aujourd'hui de faire des cures de rappel
de choses négatives dans la vie je n'en
ai pas envie bien sûr je vais lui dire
il cherche la merde
tu as raison
c'est pas mal parce que je vais te dire
la vérité ce que je pense c'est qu'un
match se gagne à 11 ça se perd à 11 et
vous avez été désigné comme le bouc
émissaire c'est ça que je veux vous dire
oui d'accord tant qu'émissaire et quand
houllier deal a commis un crime contre
l'équipe de france je trouve ça ridicule
parce qu'ils avaient aussi laurent blanc
il ya des cantona y avait pas pas il y
avait tout le monde donc hériter tomber
sur vous c'est ça que je vais vous dire
je n'en parle pas pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai des enfants que je
n'ai pas envie que ça soit justement des
cure de rappel pour toutes les jeunes
générations c'est à dire que tous les
dix ans on va rappeler aux nouvelles
générations que en 93 david ginola a
fait un centre trop long et que la
france 2 s'est pas qualifiée pour la
coupe du monde aux états unis il faut le
dire quand même à notre fils est pas un
livre et une émission si c'est pas une
émission c'est un article effectivement
il ya eu ce but de kostadinov dans la
dernière minute au tout le monde le sait
mais ceci étant à l'époque tous les
clubs où veulent le real vous le milan
ac vous veut le barça vous veut vous
choisissez newcastle et vous devenez
avec cantona la star du football anglais
oui sauf que sauf qu'en 98 aimé jacquet
vous ne sélectionne pas je sais mais
sélectionne pas quand je vois l'équipe
de france gagner à coup du moins 90 pour
moi c'est je vois tous ces gens qui sont
en train de se donner la main dans toute
la france sur les champs elysées
vraiment une image très positive de la
seule cette nuit là et vous pleurez je
suis peut-être en est un des rares à
avoir pleuré à ce moment là parce que je
me remette à will survive
oui mais c'est plus profond que ça c'est
à dire que quand vous rêvez à 9 ans
d'être de de faire un métier que dix ans
après vous réaliser ce rêve vous passez
tout votre vie à faire ça et que vous
lui donnez 100 % de votre temps vous
il vous manque quelque chose c'est la
dernière fois qu'on en parle non rendez
vous des gens des gens qui leur sert le
même nom
alors 2016
vous êtes en 2016 pardon qui arrive qu
est ce qui s'est passé exactement belga
s'il s'est pas d'embrouillés
alors qu'en 2007 il a été un bon sens
vous êtes consultant sur canal en 2016
quand ils sont trop cons
[Rires]
michel calogine la satw après ce qu'il a
eue si tu peux m'énerver et relative
tout maintenant donc en 2016 êtes sur
canal quand m6 vous recrutent donc pour
l'euro canal mamane a donné les clés
d'une émission qui s'appelle match of
the day premier footballeur à avoir son
émission c'était vraiment à voir qu'on
vous un conducteur une oreillette des
gens voilà
et là j désolé mais c'est à nouveau le
drame
[Applaudissements]
trois semaines avant de prendre
l'antenne ou jouer au foot avec des
potes à mandelieu la napoule près de
cannes et vous êtes victime d'un arrêt
cardiaque ce qui est extraordinaire dans
votre histoire si vous êtes sauvés par
une infirmière qui le matin même
augmenté par l'ascenseur était monté par
les escaliers à lévis qui avait un
terrain en hélicoptère pouvait se poser
et quand on lui apprend par son bip
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a été victime
d'un arrêt cardiaque elle vit on peut
poser un hélicoptère à cet endroit je l'
ai vu ce matin c'est comme un miracle
ceux-ci l'ascenseur avait marché cette
fille n'aurait pas su ça il ya corps qui
a maille pokora et ça ils vous font de
cette dernière et des bulgares
cardiaque essais et c'est très bien de
la part de m pokora enfin massage
cardiaque parce que au départ et
préférer cantona
quand tout vous fait un malaise
cardiaque sur un terrain de football il
ya tout qui s'arrête donc vous ne vous
rendez pas compte de ce qui se passe
vous tombez votre coeur s'arrête vous
êtes mort il ya des gens qui ont fait le
nécessaire ils m'ont sauvé cerveau en
faisant pratiquer un massage cardiaque
pendant 8 9 minutes
en attendant que les premiers secours
arrivent les pompiers sont arrivés ils
ont en sortir des fruits d'atr ils m'ont
choqué trois fois ils ont regardé tout
le monde et ils ont dit mais votre ami m
c'est fini donc ils ont essayé une
quatrième fois une cinquième fois la
cinquième fois le curé au parti illico
père est arrivé moi ils m'ont emmené à
un monaco j'ai l'impression de regus
professeur gilles de refus ce qui m'a
opéré en partant on en parlait aussi
avec michel je lui disais il me dit
david avant que tu sortes il faut que je
te dise quelque chose il me dit voilà je
te regarde là tu as perdu 3,4 kg ça fait
dix jours que tu es avec nous tu vas
travailler il me dit mais il faut que je
te dise que c'est un miracle c'est
vraiment un miracle avait neuf chances
sur dix que tu ne sortent pas karim taj
cardiaque sauf que ceux qui t'ont vrai
vraiment sauvé la vie ce sont des amis
sur le terrain frédéric mendy olivier
girault
m pokora est avec nous la semaine
prochaine regardez votre caméra à ce
qu'ils aient quelque chose à lui dire à
part qu'il arrête de chanter
non mais je joue j'ai eu du mal a appelé
tous ceux qui ont participé à ce
sauvetage parce que juste le fait de
leur dire merci pour moi c'était pas
suffisant donc aujourd'hui c'est je le
serai toujours reconnaissant mais pas
que pour moi pour mes enfants une fois
qu'on s'en va plus pour nous je réalise
en fait que nous si j'étais parti
devrait absolument rien ressenti est ce
que le fait d'en revenir et d'être là
pour en parler on se dit mais si j'avais
j'étais parti ça aurait été la même
chose donc aujourd'hui c'est être là
pour les siens pour ceux qu'on aime et
le reste thierry je m'en fous c'est on
va droit ou à l'essentiel on aime ou on
n'aime pas mais si c'est le cas alors
vous avez un mot à dire un des gants
mais que je les aime beaucoup parce
qu'il était là et qu'il a il a il a
aussi contribué à ce que les choses
s'accélèrent pour pour que je sois là en
train d'en parler alors au moins est ce
qu'ils avaient acheté son dernier album
non pas encore mais j'ai le jeu les
écouter en exclusivité bien avant qu'ils
sortent alors le lendemain le maroc et
le malaise
pour réveiller avec toutes vos facultés
ya aucune séquelle souffre d'être
animateur sur m6
je trouve ça remarquable d'avoir la
possibilité de goûter à des tas de
choses bien c'est à dire que de faire
l'euro sur m6 où on a vraiment je dis
qu'à retourner parce que c'était
vraiment cas avec des pics pour la
finale à 25 millions de téléspectateurs
je pense je pense que ça a été vraiment
une réussite et m6 décide à ce moment-là
de vous confier la présentation de la
france a un incroyable talent on a un
incroyable ginola
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
ils ne seront pas prêts pour la nouvelle
saison
[Musique]
si avec un bon entraînement et en jouant
collectif
saint jean à la
france a un incroyable
talent sur m6 alors vous voilà devenu
animateur télé pour le moment ça se
passe bien question de rhodes vous en
moquez c'est
super la france a un incroyable talent
vous vous avez un incroyable talent si
celui de de ne pas mourir désormais
quand vous entendez à will survive c'est
pour vous maintenant la chance non elle
ne sera jamais voulait pas longtemps non
je ne la met pas s'il va leur parler de
la bulgare petya non non non j'en mets
une autre
[Musique]
charest
c'est un beau gosse ou pas
si beau voyage
l'autre vous n'êtes pas que sada guide
vous êtes vraiment c'est vous êtes super
moi je suis complètement son charme
alors laissez le déblatérer vraiment
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu il ya eu pas
mal de discussions je savais que si je
trouve ça super réducteur parce que on
s'arrête à ce genre de choses et puis en
plus quand on est issu du football on
sait encore plus réducteur parce qu'on
s'imagine c'est
non mais t'es des acteurs la gueule de
ribéry c'est quoi ton problème non s'est
passé ailleurs je sais c'est pas ça
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt le c'est
plutôt la nato à réflexion on va vous
êtes très beau
[Applaudissements]
mes poules
[Musique]
non mais vous raconter une anecdote qui
n'est pas drôle mais j'ai eu le malheur
cet été en vacances de voir un type se
noyer par des mentions de mes yeux et on
l'a sorti de l'eau et pendant une heure
on lui a fait un massage cardiaque et
est le type était mort dès le début et
tout le monde y croyait et pendant une
heure on s'est relayé pour faire le
massage cardiaque en mettant des claques
en l'élisant revenant revenant et j'ai
je pensais à toi parce que je sais que
c'est un miracle intervenue à la 6e fois
où il voit la suisse avait un truc pas
drôle de type est mort moi c'est pas non
mais c'est vrai mais ce qui est arrivé
ce qui est arrivé à david c'est
effectivement miraculeux parce que des
fibres il est choqué pendant six fois
pour que le coeur redémarre déjà il
fallait que les types y croit encore et
qu'ils erreurs envoyé le
le choc et que ça redémarre et mais
surtout s'il n'y avait pas eu les
massages cardiaques
et même si le coeur avait redémarré
david aujourd'hui il aurait été donneurs
d'organes donc il serait pas il s'en
serait pas sortie parce que le cerveau
aurait pas été irrigué suffisamment si
le cerveau est pas irrigué par dont deux
termes à peine trois minutes mais ça
veut dire que il faut impérativement
c'est une publicité david pour les
gestes de premiers secours
extraordinaires et son accident parce
que c'est david ginola a permis de faire
une publicité a donné envie à des gens
d'aller faire des d'apprendre les gestes
de premiers secours il suffit de pas
grand chose quoi quelques heures pour
apprendre à masser la grande cause
nationale 2016 sans justement les
premiers gestes qui sauvent et on a fait
avec la croix rouge avec
la protection civile et les sapeurs
pompiers on a fait avec bernard
cazeneuve on a lancé la campagne parce
qu'il n'y a que 15 % dans la population
française qui connaissent déjà les
premiers gestes qui sauvent crier mort à
côté de moi mais y'a pas confié qu'il
voulait pas il est ponctuel et la place
semble trop long
[Applaudissements]
alors faute est question pourquoi c'est
pas appris dans les écoles ça c'est ça
va l'être en savane lettre mais il a là
c'est parce que mais c'est même pas ça
sait qui il est il est pas normal
aujourd'hui qu'en france on puisse
passer son permis de conduire sans être
passés par l'apprentissage de premiers
secours c'est aussi simple que ça alors
dis moi comment il était dans cet état
là à dire qu'il n'avait pas fait de
checa qui savait pas qu'il avait un
cabinet c'est que david hill et ancien
joueur de haut niveau sont qu'à priori
très sain et en même temps il avait
quand même nom mais après il a beau il
est peut-être la vie par les deux bouts
j'en sais rien mais il ya beaucoup de
choses héréditaire et à il ya beaucoup
de choses héréditaire que ce soit des
problèmes familiaux des antécédents
familiaux justement il des problèmes
cardiaques papa maman ont eu des
problèmes maman est partie vous aviez
enfin les artères bouchées des trucs
comme ça 6 cd coronaire bouchée alors si
vous faites des check-up ça se voit
c'est pas un check up qu'il aurait dû
avoir c'est une épreuve d'effort pour
l'ars qui a un certain âge on doit quand
on fait du sport en plus il continue en
faire on doit avoir un
électrocardiogramme et une épreuve
d'effort pour voir si le coeur tient
mais un check up général ne sert à rien
si on n'a pas de symptômes
[Musique]
nous et on bosse maintenant un autre
tété ou de la semaine
alors c'est qu'on diffuse cette chanson
toutes les semaines est ce que ça te
fait du blé à la sacem
non pas celle à la merde je suis un con
le diffusant
sa fédé sous alain chamfort et bergman
bergman c'est bien on a fait gagner
encore un peu
c
des gens
tu en as fait des belles chansons
on écoute didier
[Musique]
m
bonjour
hier
[Musique]
je ne
ja
m
[Musique]
gk
m
pourquoi
[Musique]
oh
qui
[Musique]
liot
[Applaudissements]
alors lyon se retrouve après la pub pour
des questions beaucoup plus gênant david
ginola merci d'avoir été
plus avoir envie de nous servons
successfull sa nouvelle vie
salil shetty napper de sauce
[Musique]
et b
la mention l'intérieur annonçant les
terriens sommes de retour ce chanteur
toujours encore banni de michel cymes
non seulement
il maintenant on pense à notre deuxième
tu es au top
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
châtiment liste d'acteurs bull est la
star de la série fais pas ci fais pas ça
sur france 2 vous êtes ce fou génial qui
triomphe actuellement sur la scène du
petit montparnasse avec euphorique vous
êtes celui qui a débuté avec jean
dujardin et surtout on vient de
l'apprendre vous êtes l'ex de julie
gayet
je suis l'ex de françois hollande va
sonder connu julie gayet quoi ouais donc
non mais
vous avez le début dans une émission
mythique bruno salomone
[Musique]
une émission qui s'appelait graines de
stars que je produisais vous étiez le
premier gagnant de l'émission avec un
sketch qui s'appelait la caissière vous
souvenez du ska vie jolie en marraine
ressurgir ce faire beat by night
j'étais très très ému et très aimée
émission de télé il y avait une sorte
d'adrénaline à quoi m et dès que tu
entendais de génériques comme ça tu
rentres dans un état de fait les choses
donc il ya eu évidemment graines de
stars la caissière gros succès il y
avait aussi ça
[Musique]
carrez
vue sur la mer ça c'est une solution
visait aussi à tourner à côté du
lavandou galore il ya un jour où ce
crooner de salomone m'a piégé dans un
taxi les chauffeurs de taxi et puis on
parle ça dure 40 minutes à la fin je dis
des trucs un peu intime en garde à quoi
sert ce
qui arrive charles
rien république l'autre jour j'ai voulu
aller virer tellement si ça continue je
vais évacue rsm moi je suis content
je suis content non ça ne c'est pas vous
qui me saouler c'est le fait qu'à 26
personnes qui n'attendait que je vois
pas quelle heure on va arriver
[Musique]
tesla sont des temps réalisés allez-y
j'ai trouvé comme eurostar et ça c'est
un pote quitter saint seurin tard
[Musique]
continue continue stéphane stéphane
thiery c'est plus loin c'est plus loin
thierry pierre clément way et le 6
janvier 1941 c'est plus loin steph
stéphane
vous étiez au collège saint michel azzi
1 à la faculté de lettres de montpellier
un fils de victor ardisson 1 et de
madame juliette rené gastinel je pouvais
pas oublier tout ça comme tu le sais
samedi dernier fortis
pour te battre ouais ouais ouais
tu te faire [ __ ] il y avait un taxi
jamais rentable
fort
[Applaudissements]
ce
qui est très drôle c'est que au moment
où jean lève la période tu me reconnais
toujours pas
aujourd'hui bruno salomone vous
triomphez sur la scène du petit théâtre
montparnasse dans un faux rythme c'est
l'histoire de gaulle riz un jeune homme
qui rigole tout le temps quoi qu'il
arrive c'est alessandra sublet qui vous
a inspiré le personnage
c'est un peu ce qu'on ce qu'on nous dit
dans notre pays on dit vous devez vous
marrer tout le temps non il ya un petit
côté je lui tiens c'est ça serait
marrant de faire un personnage qui se
marre tout le temps et je mets 10 son
entourage va devenir dingue et ça c'est
un prétexte de retrouver plein de
situations complètement délirant il est
né en riant galerie guides aînées en
riant mais les boutiques dans moi aussi
je suis en rien quoi qu'il arrive et là
tu peux le pain c'est le torturer
d'ailleurs rien asie dans le spectacle
de torture dirigea la roumanie ce maïs
marquant même alors nous raconter cette
histoire à travers quarante trois
personnages notre préférée c'est loin
mais il y en a plein qui était dans mon
précédent spectacle j'aime beaucoup
comme michael d'amour par lequel un
chanteur d'amour qui avait une sorte de
mecque un peu comme ça comme tout le
monde qui trouvent tous super sur de
fusion entre dao et fogiel tu vois un
[Applaudissements]
homme
comme les autres car il était
en permanence chine est malade galerie
qui est logique moi j'adore me la piste
aux étoiles je fais la pieuvre et le
congrès rappelle qu'un bon petit
spectacle rafraîchissant avec un
professionnel du divertissement
[Applaudissements]
ses coûts et à kehl c'est petit
montparnasse fassi de rugby qui m'ont
battu mon passé derrière le grand mont
pas
c'est facile c'est à 21h rue maghribiya
que des gars que des théâtres tout le
sceau du mardi au samedi et je double
samedi à 16 heures si tu ne sais pas
faire un petit goûter
alors bien ça donc fric oui et puis à
brice de nice 3 allée jean dujardin et
clovis cornillac en salles le 19 octobre
ça s'est bien passé les gens voient
carrément franchement il y en a plus
d'un qui sera contraire pourtant il est
passé de ça
à ça ça
va diffuser de la pub à l'époque c'était
ça ouais et aujourd'hui c'est ça
[Rires]
ah mais la note est vachement plus
marrante c'est bien brice de nice 3 ça
vaut le coup carrément bon sang qu'est
du budget dont convient il ya 17
millions d'euros quand même hein et en
plus il ya un vrai parti pris l'un que
c'est étonnant pour une comédie
française on regarde à quoi ça
[Musique]
brice c'est ton meilleur ami par ces
cours rejoint mois au plus vite quand le
premier avion [ __ ]
[Musique]
le premier avion s'il te plaît oui le
premier avion pour vous après je sais
pas
[Musique]
[ __ ]
ça
semble un bon vin
[Musique]
fallu un bon coup de presse qui pousse
mettaient pas en danger ah non c'est un
droit qui suivent en danger tais toi qu
en danger
[Musique]
t'es cru que tu allais voir tout le film
brice
3,6 et
la bri 3 de james huth avec jean
dujardin bruno salomone suis dedans je
suis pas dans la bande annonce mais je
suis dedans tu es dans le final ce qui
est étonnant c'est la prouesse de gens
aussi qui fait plein de personnages que
je vais pas vous raconter mais il se
fait lui même
je veux pas vendre un petit peu
d'histoire mais se fait lui même à une
autre époque l'institut c'est tout ce
que je peux dire c'est très délirant
c'est assez délirant c'est plus délirant
le premier c'est beaucoup plus délirant
que le pro mais voilà les aficionados à
mon avis vont voir des rennais autre
fausse drogués
alors c'est marrant parce que vous
porter chance à votre entourage jean
dujardin a récupéré un oscar viguier a
récupéré france là
mais quand j'y repense puis tout s'est
tu perds et
à les brancher comique ou quoi parce que
hollande est faux
le film papale familles décomposées
alors il paraît que vous vous retrouviez
dans une maison sur les bords de marne
avec talent une livre bah j'ai vu les
vanniers détruites décevant c'est pas
des fois j'allais en scooter
je dors donc j'adore parce que je m'y
attendais pas du tout c est ce conte
dans le cake ce de julie gali vous les
décors et la légion d'honneur
bonjour j'ai même pas envie de répondre
mais répond pas mais on ne sait pas ça
tout ça c'est des cds légende de ta
baiser juin
[Applaudissements]
si l'on mange ta soupe aller
les
gens m'ont guidée vous ne serez pas
étonné qu'on fasse une interview jean
dujardin
[Musique]
oui non oui c'est moi en quoi
aujourd'hui
je sais que j'ai baisé ta femme aussi
sans quoi jean dujardin que c'est utile
parfois un peu lourd je sais pas en
compte en banque
quel film de jean dujardin que je vous
reverrai jamais bizarrement on a
commencé ensemble on s'est inspiré ça
fait un peu machin mais j'aime j'aime
bien le gars j'aime bien ce qui fait
s'échanger pas de mal à dire intérêt ça
fait chier à vous avez bien qu'on dit du
mal qu est-ce qui pue de la gueule qu'il
faut absolument dire du mal de tu veux
que je te dise la vérité de quoi il a
des gros malin non c'est que je savais
que tu réagirais comme ça pourquoi et
j'ai dit on arrêtera l'interview au bout
de la troisième question
vient à lui quand même
qu'est ce que est ce que jean dujardin
baiser julie gayet
[Applaudissements]
m
pour les messieurs
[Applaudissements]
20 millions de disques vendus 25 films
six enfants un gros tas tout de fleurs
sur l'épaule douce traversée du désert
quelques des primes mais toujours dit
désert c'est vrai ça vient de là
portugaises ensablées au exactement
un beau la toile magnifique j'aurai un
quiz après sur les tatouages m'a fallu
tout de suite alors faut deviner à qui
appartient le tatouage allons-y tu vois
là il s'est dit je n'ai d'une agglo et
le moins bon
après
facile les uns
ça au maire seul johnny hallyday
jean luc lahaye
c'était pourtant passé la suivant
ainsi l'union
à bas mais je ne fais pas mais enfin
c'est facile c'est blanche même
tendancieuses ton style émis mardi enfin
regarder
celui d'anna ouais c'est vincent bolloré
bravo
vas-y
ça c'est la patronne de france 3 non dan
astier non à samuel et jamel et
thierry dernier le dernier
est beau serge est là il est très très
beau issus de la personne non c'est que
philippe geluck
j'arrivais tous les deux alors lions
la première fois qu'on s'est rencontrés
c'était au début des années 80
je faisais une série pour un magazine
qui s'appelle rock et folk j'ai une
série intitulée descente de police lit
décidé de transformer l'interview en
interrogatoire rue sous les regards des
sas et l arrestation
et après il y avait les aveux
et en fait gérard louvin qui était votre
manager à l'époque
m'avait dit mais tu sais elle pleure
pour de vrai
les pleurs pour de vrai parce que
c'était fait à cause d' alain chamfort
tjrs amoureuse d'alain chamfort oui jean
faure il avait plaqué la mère de ses
enfants pour vous mais moi je savais pas
qu'il était avec une femme des hommes
disent pas ces choses là tout de suite
et voilà c'était c'était compliqué pour
moi j'étais très jeune j'avais 17 ans
c'était oui c'était dur je passais ma
journée à côté du 10/10 téléphone et
voilà c'était difficile et ce jour là je
pleurais vraiment
la soie
j'avais dû bien d'écouter sa mère dans
ces jeunes lorsque m
c'est l'époque de banana split
évidemment quand je pense que j'ai
toujours cru que cette chanson parlé de
fellation en fait ça parlait d'une glace
à la vanille mais vous avez déclaré en
fait c'est un hommage à kevin ayers le
bassiste de soft machine et adorait les
bananes qui avait d'ailleurs une édition
qui s'appelait banane amour alors
jacques duval qu elle parodie de la
chanson a dit en fait lio savait très
bien ce qu'elle chante et c'est pas du
tout france gall qui faisait semblant de
pas savoir que les sucettes à l'anis
c'était autre chose mais fin france
calle le savais vraiment pas mais moi je
trouve que c'était gaz bourque était le
vieux libidineux dégueulasse va alors ça
est ce que serge gainsbourg a essayé de
partouzer avec vous et alain chamfort
serge si tu nous regardes
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous êtes ici pour la tournée
car quatre vingt dix ans déjà ça veut
dire que les gens sont déjà nostalgique
de nostalgie puisque
moi j'adore cette tournée j'adore être
avec ces gens je m'ennuie pas une
seconde de rechanter banana split où les
brunes ou fallait pas pour moi c'est des
cd classique j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
chanter ses chansons alors 53 dates en
france du 4 novembre 2016 au 6 mai 2010
est alors il ya des nouveaux il ya
plastic bertrand qui revient il ya
thierry pastor tu te souviens de thierry
pastor le coup de folie
[Musique]
y at il besoin il ya johnny jamison
évidemment
juba au fait moi je
tu sais
regard à
380 à tourner toutes les stars de ces
années culte remonte sur scène pour
fêter les 10 ans de leur tournée
événement dans les options et on est
parti dans un vaisseau spatial une
véritable machine à remonter le temps
qui compte plus de trois millions de
spectateurs
mis en scène cette année par chris
marquès star quatre-vingt dix ans déjà
en tournée dans toute la france dès le 4
novembre 2016 est au zénith de paris les
13 14 et 15 mars 2017 avec des trains et
cars quatre-vingt dix ans déjà
comme disait jean luc lahaye dix ans
c'est beaucoup
alors les jeunes et tout votre bouquin
mauvaise mère chez fayard vous le fait
ou pas pourquoi mais parce que si je
dois parler de moi en tant que maire je
dois forcément parler de mes enfants et
ça donne pas que du bon jeu j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps à comprendre
j'avais pas trop de filtres tu vas je
pensais qu'on pouvait parler de tout
d'une manière un peu sympathique mais en
fait non c'est un média en coupe des
choses et ils en ont beaucoup souffert
et moi je m'en suis aperçu j'ai plus du
tout envie de de les mettre dans cette
situation donc je ferais pas ça oui vous
avez pas envie de dire que vous l'avez
pas accordé assez d'attention à vos
enfants mais je crois que tous les gens
qui réussissent ont le même sentiment de
culpabilité non j'ai pas de sentiment de
culpabilité je pense que j'ai un peu
raté ma fonction
parentale je pense était une très bonne
maman ouais mais pas forcément une
excellente mère tout le temps le été
influencé par 68 +69
mais j'aime pas tous aux samoa a fait
contre ce faire les deux en même temps
tu trouves pas déjà on nettoie les
outils
non mais c'est vrai dit oh vous été
influencé par il est interdit
d'interdire on a tous été influencé par
ça ça marche pas il est interdit
d'interdire il faut surtout accepter
d'être un vieux con pour son enfant je
pense que tu as beaucoup de mal avec ça
tire et as tu veux rester jeune dans le
coup c'est pour ça tu as une émission
super et c'est compliqué pour les
enfants de voir que leur père veut pas
vieillir je te le dire
alors les grands tubes évidemment sont
dans star 80 et 1
et dans les pubs donc on va voir qui
vous reconnaissez les chansons qui ont
été massacrés par les pubs on va faire
un blind test musique de pub à
[Musique]
on se concentre on est quand tout le
monde joue didier
j'adore
[Musique]
à l'est plus c'est terrible comme les
ont mal ça quelle chanson didier
baby come back baby come back oui il est
l'interprète s'apprête les beatles
habitat na vi nichols
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
mais
ça va faire c'est c'est mozart îles et
îlots bistrot il arrive il ya bac es en
train de boire un whisky au bar ils
savent à toi tu es à vakili de pêche tu
prends eux
et dis moi je prends la baby come back
est celle que tu m'as un conducteur
c'est le belge ah oui c'est un belge il
m a dit avoir le docteur et puis le
docteur est dégoûté messieurs j'ai des
mauvaises nouvelles pour vous j'ai vu
vos analyses il vous reste deux mois à
vivre le belge dit c'est pas grave je
vais prendre jeux vidéo
attention on se concentre c'est
introuvable didier
[Musique]
il va
plus beaux buts charest
sa saison bon live si cela est plus
simple
mon
dieu c'est mon époque
[Musique]
massage pas
attention
[Applaudissements]
il faut le temps que ça passe par
l'oreille que ça arrive dans la partie
de l'audition et ensuite que ça rentre
dans l'hippocampe pour éventuellement je
me souvienne de quelque chose donc je
reviendrai demain
attention du dieu
tout pour ma chérie
je
dur
non laisse répondre sans ballon si l'on
connaît une
fin pour michel hamm un point pour les
ehpad et
dj
c'est la moisson première
m
animations
en parler
c'est là du tout
nostalgie quand tu nous tiens de la
guerre
[Musique]
en fait j'aurais passé ma vie à faire
des blagues te laisse pas mal comme job
tu as trouvé le bon boulot je suis des
bétons niveau d'études
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces mises à jour je ne fais que te lou
dobbs félicie aussi
attention
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est mieux c'est quoi
donadoni les mauvais sans fil
dégueulasse autour et ça c'est les
sandwichs pas bon client gagne et
stéphane ont fait une pub d'enfer
l'eau mazine
ça m'étonne pas
voilà c'était la paix 3d on se retrouve
avec guillon jeunes u17 et la batterie
[Musique]
hélas
au re bonsoir était rien bon vent
bonsoir les terriens nous sommes de
retour sur terre toujours en compagnie
de michel cymes
bruno salomone
et maintenant les messieurs c'est le
moment de grille en 2017
[Applaudissements]
sell list of fame à stéphane
doucement avec bolloré parce que je
viens d'arriver
et une charrette
[Rires]
on commence avec une nouvelle assez
triste les appels au secours des
agriculteurs suicidaires ont explosé
1700 appel de détresse par an les
paysans devraient appeler directement
karine le marchand
oui bernard c'est karine à l'appareil
vous voulez vous suicidez vous êtes
interdit bancaire deux cent mille euros
de dettes ou assez dure c'est dur alors
j'ai peut-être quelqu'un à vous proposer
bernard elle s'appelle marine à la 48
ans elle est blonde généreuse alors
petit bémol vous n'êtes pas son type
d'homme non maintenant elle son truc ce
sont les grands shows va raquer
skinheads néonazis
elle fait des scènes fille avec eux mais
attention faut pas la diaboliser bernard
un marine c'est quelqu'un de très doux
qui aiment la nature les hortensias et
qui fait des far aux pruneaux comme
personne c'est pourquoi elle ajoute des
pommes de danse est son secret bon alors
on pose son fusil bernard fidh et les
bêtises et on organise une rencontre à
meyrargues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on passe à la politique
tient
aux déclarations de bruno le maire dans
l'intimité ma femme me surnomme co quito
on s'en fout
s'en fout complètement gecko quito
poquito pepito
[Applaudissements]
deux autres déclarations de bruno le
maire cette semaine la drogue est une
vraie inquiétude pour moi et c'est très
important la nature
il ya combien de semaines encore avant
le premier tour de la primaire dirais
que je je je vais pas tenir je suis
appelé peut pas tenir
[Musique]
immigration
grâce aux migrants la suède connaît une
croissance exceptionnelle ils sont casse
couille ces migrants comment marine le
pen sarkozy laurent wauquiez robert
ménard ils vont faire de la politique si
ça va mieux grâce aux migrants ils sont
chiants oui font rien comme tout le
monde ils arrivent en bateau ils savent
pas nager faut aller les chercher
et si dans le lot il y en a un qui sait
nager alors là qu est ce qui fait qu
est-ce qui fait il sauve trois fillette
de la noyade à esperanza dans le
roussillon genre moi je sais nager je
frime si l'idée si l'idée c'est de nous
contredire en permanence de nous
humilier c'est pas la peine de traverser
la méditerranée
[Applaudissements]
en allemagne un djihadiste interpellé
grâce à des réfugiés syriens
robert ménard a raison ils vont nous
remplacer ils vont nous remplacer mais
en mieux
[Applaudissements]
christian estrosi perd son procès contre
le rappeur infinite qui avait chanté je
n'ai aucun diplôme comme christian
estrosi on écoute un extrait on se fait
plaisir
[Musique]
à noter que christian estrosi n'a fait
aucun procès à sarkozy dj sarko qui
pourtant l'avait qualifié d'abrutis
ayant une noisette dans la tête
[Applaudissements]
pas très sympa pour les noisettes ou
écologie anne hidalgo a reçu le soutien
d' arnold schwarzenegger dans sa lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
tenez bon lui at il écrit ne cédez pas
arnold souhaite rencontrer la mère de
paris ok ok c'est d'accord mais surtout
quand il arrive à paris il appelle qu'on
bloque la circulation sinon il ne
passera pas il appelle le chauffeur
d'hidalgo pierre à pierre pierre sfr
sens interdits voies de bus feu rouge
motards gyrophare il passe partout il
appelle un ah si l'appel passé l'horreur
cul à cul etc les ploucs les ouvriers
les commerçants tous ces cons qui vont
travailler à respirer les pots
d'échappement l'ordre et la paix lane
c'est un numéro vert xian tout est vert
accident à pantin une femme a été
percutée par un train alors qu'elle se
penchait pour vomir
on a remplacé les intercités par des tgv
on a les premiers résultats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher
médias eric zemmour maintenue sur rtl
malgré la consternation de la direction
yves calvi a grondé le journaliste en
direct
et réitéré qu on te garde mais on est
très fâché faire l'apologie du
terrorisme je le dis à nos auditeurs
c'est pas joli joli c'est kaka a rtl on
est vent debout la prochaine fois je le
dis à nos auditeurs eric c'est un blâme
[Musique]
dis-moi
dis-moi coco il a fait combien
d'auditeurs ce matin eric 2 millions à
hilla et son café sa moto taxi tout va
bien ah c'est quand même une très très
belle plume oui oui je l embrasse pour
toi j'ai lembras
[Musique]
tu te rappelles de cette émission sur
rtl elle et les routiers sont sympas un
show avec max monnier
pourrait peut-être faire les djihadistes
sont chouettes animé par eric zemmour
repas ou rtl rtl
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
télévision malgré une mise en examen
pour corruption de mineur jean marc
morandini arrive la semaine prochaine
sur i télé le profil si vous êtes
journaliste et souhaitez travailler au
côté de jean-marc être mineur de sexe
masculin et surtout être motivés sans
barrières sans tabou les conférences de
rédaction auront lieu la nuit dans le
sommet personnel de jean marc envoyez
vos cv à catherine leclerc accompagné
d'une photo dénudée
l'info à nu c'est tous les jours à 18h
sur i télé
showbiz céline dion sert la mort latex
de rené angélil avant chaque
représentation
est ce que d'autres parties du corps de
rené ont été moulés ce serait bien que
céline nous tiennent informés quand
elles rentrent seul de son show avec gas
c'est vrai que ça m'aide à dormir depuis
crown est mort il ne mange plus le petit
plomb heureusement j'avais versé schnall
en latex et je me passe un poignet toute
seule même si un plus sirop d'érable
avis qui dans mille feuilles c'est
toujours ça de pris tanks et son char ça
fait du sens
on embrasse la
littérature événements cette semaine
avec la sortie d'un livre retraçant cinq
ans de confidences de françois hollande
un florilège de pensée de citations le
président se livre dans ce chef-d'oeuvre
qui marquera le panthéon de la
littérature française extraits
l'obsession de valérie trierweiler ce
n'était pas julie c'était sigolène
rupture été le pire moment du
quinquennat julie souffrent de cette
situation elle est demandeuse se brûle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai c'est magnifique et du
banquier tout le livre est comme ça tu
vois tout le livre de cette qualité
pompidou qui cite le poète paul eluard à
côté c'est de la merde
familles ont trouvé
d'ici là
sur scène à paris
descendre on passe maintenant à la
bataille des idées du championnat open
[Musique]
et c'est gilles lartigau l'auteur du
best seller it que nous accueillerons
sur ce plateau après le magnéto battle
de ce soit alimentation du poison dans
nos assiettes
[Musique]
selon l'insee les français achètent les
trois quarts de ce qu'ils mangent dans
les supermarchés le problème c'est qu'en
confiant notre alimentation aux grandes
surfaces et aux industriels de
l'agroalimentaire
nous leur confions aussi notre santé et
ça est ce que c'est vraiment du solide
on a d'abord eu la crise de la vache
folle ensuite le plus à la dioxine et
puis le vieux cheval lavagne sans
oublier les tartes okaka chez ikea après
chaque scandale dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire les pouvoirs publics
nous promettent ça va s'arranger il n'y
a pas eu de traces de différents
produits susceptibles de nuire à la
santé d'avoir des risques pour la santé
sauf qu'à chaque fois va recommence
découvrez les délices du nouveau g multi
pesticides une farandole d'insecticides
et autres perturbateurs endocriniens
dont leclerc ne souhaite pas parler
alors puisque c'est si divisé changer le
monde pourquoi ne pas commencer par
changer nos propres habitudes
c'est tromper parce que si on finit par
ressembler à ce qu'on mange eh ben c'est
pas joli joli commençons par le petit
déj observez bien si vous prenez un bol
de mously en croyant que c'est bon pour
la santé faites gaffe on a appris cette
semaine qu à moins que ça soit un
produit bio le muscle est rempli de
pesticides alors vous vous posez votre
question alors tant pis passons au
déjeuner un petit blanc de poulet avec
de la salade pour garder la ligne ben si
ce n'est pas révolté de voir comment les
poules sont traités dans les élevages
industriels
pourquoi pas mais sachez quand même que
sur une centaine d'échantillons de
volaille testés par que choisir un quart
étaient contaminés par des bactéries oui
et même avec la salade ou ce métier sur
trente et une salade acheté l'an dernier
en supermarché 80% contenaient des
pesticides parfois cancérigènes sans
doute la meilleure dès les classes berg
dans son libre gilles lartigau a
interrogé le cancérologue pierre marie
martin il lui tire le signal d'alarmé
quel que soit votre âge vous avez
l'alimentation que accélérer accélérer
vous avez entendu
ralentir un ancien sur deux alors qu'est
ce que vous avez prévu pour votre dîner
un petit plat surgelé avec une belle
photo sur la boîte mais peut-être
préparer à de minerai de viande bon
finalement vous savez ce qu'on va faire
pour le dîner un ragoût de tofu bio avec
une bonne sauce au jus de blé même si
c'est dégueulasse au moins c'est bon
pour la santé
et voilà c'était les visionner bientôt
mise en image de julien gracq pilati
bonsoir j'ai été musicien produit qu'a
appris mais surtout vous êtes l'auteur
du best seller it
chronique d'un fauve dans la jungle
alimentaire publié chez winter fise
bienvenue parmi nous alors gilles vous
donner les conférences dans le monde
entier pour dénoncer l'exploitation
animale et l'industrialisation notre
nourriture on vous appelle le gourou du
bien manger alors s'empoisonne ton tous
les jours avec ce qu'on mange par quoi
faut-il remplacer cette nourriture
toxique on va voir on va commencer avec
les perturbateurs endocriniens
vous avez vu l'étude parue cette semaine
le mutli moi je mange du muesli tous les
matins et je m'aperçois que dans un bol
de musli il ya un maximum de pesticides
alors vous recommander pas désiré à
l'inde moi je suis pas très fan des
mousselines mais des perturbateurs
endocriniens on vous en avait deux
partout puisque en fait ils sont dans
les pesticides et les engrais en fait ce
sont des dérivés des gaz de combat en
première et deuxième guerre mondiale
alors les perturbateurs endocriniens
il perturbe
le système hormonal et le corps en
général
micropaiement nous rendre stérile après
dix en 30 tous les matins on prend
surtout on a beaucoup moins de
spermatozoïdes est que nos grands
parents alors vous michel vous vous
connaissiez de voir les perturbateurs
endocriniens c'est vrai que le problème
aujourd'hui des perturbateurs
endocriniens il ya eu des lanceurs
d'alert aujourd'hui on en parle beaucoup
et à juste titre mais l'histoire des
mots sylla qui est sorti cette semaine
oui à des résidus de pesticides dans le
multi et quand on donne du métier à nos
enfants on aimerait mieux qu'ils mangent
autre chose en même temps il faut pas
dire que c'est qu'on mange que des
pesticides en mangeant du messti
aujourd'hui ce qui est très clair c'est
que ces perturbateurs endocriniens qui
comme leurs noms l'indiquent perturbe
les glandes endocrines les glandes
endocrines ce sont des glandes qui
sécrètent des hormones quelle qu'elle
soit dans l'organisme ça oui il faut
commencer vraiment à se poser la
question de savoir ce qu'on mange c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que le bio est de
plus en plus recommandés parce que les
sols céréales finalement qu'ils ne
contiennent pas de pesticides sont les
céréales les müesli qu'on trouve dans
les magasins bio et comme il ya une
vraie une vraie proposition une vraie
véritable offre aujourd'hui du bio avec
des supermarchés qui s'ouvrent partout
c'est vrai qu'à certains éléments qu'on
a intérêt à les prendre dans l'est dans
la filière dure jusqu'en pas de
l'industrialisation du bio je parle de
faits des marchés paysans c'est là on
fait tout il faut aller acheter du
styrène aux aliments pour les préparer
il faut qu'on mange des aliments non
transformés
le problème c'est que 80% de notre
alimentation on l'a vu dans le sujet est
à base aujourd'hui d'aliments
transformés bruno par exemple buvez du
lait ça m'arrive de bord du lac est
plein de pesticides le lait dit lui
aussi 6 2 mais le problème c'est qu'on
n'en parle pas du problème du lait bon
après avec le facteur de croissance et
c'est bon mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
problèmes de aya des fantasmes des
lubies autour d'eux des produits
laitiers complètement hallucinant donc
oui le livre aujourd'hui est devenu
aussi pourquoi parce qu'on en consomme
trop mais surtout on consomme plus le
lait comme je dis dans mon livre que je
que ma mère allait prendre à la ferme
laitière qu'on faisait bouillir qui
d'entre vous êtes allé voir en élevage
industriel l'élevage industriel tu veux
des vaches aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
complètement immoral c'est des vaches
qui ne sortent pas dans les prix c'est
parce qu'on te vendent sur la sur la
bouteille plastique ok sur l'étiquette
donc c'est des vaches en fait qui
consomment du grain elles consomment du
grain donc des tourteaux de soja du maïs
tout ça bien sûr avec ogm avait des
pesticides donc le pesticide si tu veux
je retrouve dans le lait vous avez envie
d'écrire votre best seller it suite des
reportages en caméra cachée que vous
faisiez dans des abattoirs oui un parti
et j'ai vu des choses que j'aurais pas
dû voir du jour au lendemain si tu vas
après avoir vu les élevages industriels
et les abattoirs mon corps a refusé de
manger de la viande je fais beaucoup de
sport
la viande ça faisait partie non
alimentaire c'est faisait partie de mon
éducation aussi alimentaire de mes
habitudes alimentaires donc qu'est ce
que j'ai fait il a fallu que je
m'instruis il a fallu que j'apprenne et
là j'ai découvert la nourriture entre
guillemets végétales on avait les
protéines bien évidemment les protéines
végétales sont excellentes et on
n'arrête pas de répéter que la viande et
moi je suis un viandard
manger la viande toi je pouffe de
l'avion tout le temps mais je fais pas
ta pas touche à karine le marchand
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai là dedans aujourd'hui on sait
que on peut manger de la viande sauf si
son corps le refuser qu'on a vu les
choses mais on peut manger de la viande
mais il faut la manger raisonnablement
comme la charcuterie faut manger
raisonnablement de la viande et non pas
se taper une côte de boeuf tous les
jours si on en a les moyens bien les
vitres et 6 et de la viande bio précisé
le ça c'est très important dans la
trilogie % de la viande qu'on consomme
en fait provient d'élevages industriels
cédés à nimy tu sais quand on les
chouchoute ses amis mis les shoots aux
antibiotiques l'om est ce nous avertit
on va vers une pandémie
d'antibiorésistance donc je pense que
c'est un discours qu'il est important
que l'on tienne mais il faut apprendre
aux gens à cuisiner différemment et à
cuisiner aussi végétales par contre
c'est beaucoup d'efforts il faut du
temps et il faut pas de tomber
malheureusement dans une forme de
sectarisme
on entend trop de la part des
végétariens et végétaliens des vegan et
tout et on a tendance à basculer dans
les briquets ou rien ou touria qui s'est
calmé on a parlé mois de janvier c'est
pas du tout ce n'est pas le tout rien
non
je pense qu'il ya des enfants qui sont
en carence quand les parents sont vegan
et refuse vraiment à des tout-petits
savent pas comment fait on a des cas en
france donc faut faire attention faut
pas être faut pas que ça devienne une
secte et pig l'hygiénisme presque on dit
que les végétariens ou végétaliens son
encart ans les gens sentent à tous ceux
qui sont armés vegan ceux qui mangent
des pop corn au petit déjeuner comment
jésus certains je vois ou du pain blanc
avec du bon ou mauvais jambon ou est-ce
que tu retrouves les élus dont il est
membre marche pas de dire qu'un porte
bien il y en a des millions qui mangent
de la viande qui se porte bien j'ai pas
l'impression là aussi intéressant d'être
malade
j vous attendent un gain de jus et
tisanes le jus d'herbe de blé par
exemple adorait c'est un mélange en fait
de ne montre pas vrai d'alfalfa
d'épinards et d'herbes de jus de blé en
fait donc il ya plein de nutriments 20 6
à 6 minutes ouais ouais c'est ma rivale
au théâtre tout à l'heure la piste de
shrek c'est quoi ton
image et des douleurs abdominales
pendant ce temps ailleurs ça ça fait
quoi ça ça fait du bien c'est ah ouais c
b voire a bien appuyé un petit bout de
[Rires]
ces du junior de chasse c'est très bon
il
ya des choses extraordinaires seul tu
vois pas toi ice essayent d'arrêter
deux joueurs
et loire le lot
kg d'herbe de blé avec un petit peu mais
un peu de mon
père c'est très beau
de voir inconnue sera
prévoit près doit peut-être un petit
entracte dans
[Rires]
le jus rouge juive en quittant mélange
de cranberry et de graines des piats
exact vous avez là non par contre j'ai
juste spécial rock ça fait péter fait
péter alors c'est un jeu c'est mon
fameux juge si tu veux qu est ce qu il
ya de l'eau va remonter
c'est un juge du viril c'est du jus de
citron avec du gingembre et du curcuma
ça pique qui paraît que ça noir ouais ça
je pense que raymond hénault maire 6 là
je vais pas trop donné qu'elle jouera
jamais mélanger le jus d'herbe appareils
classés pas important c'est là qu'est ce
que c'est votre cas trop juste deux
doigts c'est quoi c'est
super sympa quand tu fasses assez
utilise parce que c'est utilisé par des
sportifs mais c'est très bon et ça comme
les inflammations et tu sais quoi alors
elle boit ça fait du bien
et en fait j'utilise beaucoup le super
animaux en fait dans votre livre vous
parlez de super aliments je vous en ai
porté quelques semaines parce que vous
savez pas ça c'est des fèves de cacao du
cru dont j'en ai flemme de cacau cru
oui c'est un ange alors oui je vous ai
fait mouche et
cdfm de gagnant en crue donc c'est plein
d'antioxydants
ce qui paraît ça donne un petit
directement sur les régimes dukan vous
élevez l'apu qui autour c'est ça qui
donne la marche
mais après on peut la hauteur que la
buissière
tu peux pas dire ça tu peux pas dire ça
je vais pas bien ça ça ne te plaît pas
est-ce que tu n'es pas habitué aux yeux
bandés d'accord et
je vais pas là
et non pas des ch'tis oui non
peut demander à gilles est ce que les
décoctions de chanvre indien est ce que
ça fait du bien
beaucoup d'études sont
la résine de cannabis l'huile de
cannabis cacao de daisy presque en effet
voilà est-ce que le cannabis soit une le
cancer docteur non mais y'a aucun
aliment qui soigne le cancer on peut
avec plein de choses faire de la
prévention avec certains aliments
certains fruits certains légumes on peut
aider à lutter contre à faire de la
prévention contre certains cancers mais
y'a rien qui va réduire une tumeur ou
qui va empêcher d'avoir une étoffe ainsi
de rire de ré android possède le rire si
tu veux mais c'est vrai je suis pas
forcément d'accord avec vous je m'excuse
1 j'ai donné 80 chevaux conférences en
europe surtout en france à chacun d'eux
à chacune de mes dates en fait j'ai
rencontré des gens qui sont venus
apporter leur témoignage donc de gens
qui ont été soignés en dehors du
protocole traditionnel allopathique de
chimio radiothérapie
il y avait tout arrêté qui sont mis sur
les cures de jeunes de jus au départ je
trouvais ça un peu étrange mais quand
j'en vois arriver un jour j'irai manger
on en revient au début de cette émission
avec steve jobs ce cas cancer du
pancréas mais pas grave oui fait partie
des 1 ou 2% qui peut s'en sortir lors
que d'habitude le cancer du pancréas une
punition trois mois après vêtements ce
connard de steve jobs écoute son
naturopathe et il commence à boire du
jus de carotte et pendant ce temps le
cancer du pancréas métastases sur le
foie alors qu'ils étaient sauvable et
quand ils décident d'aller voir la
médecine traditionnelle il est trop tard
son foie et métastasés des sciences
messes dites moi si je me trompe ou trop
bas mais l'envié jean bélanger gens
pouvaient panneaux sur la juge j'entends
vos discours a fait de bonnes choses
je suis médecin et les témoignages ce
n'est pas de la science non ce n'est pas
des élites et on ne peut pas se baser
sur alors témoigne un mois ignatieff
d'études sur des gens qui ont été
soignés avec des cures de jeunes des
cure de jus de légumes pas sans aucune
issue de ne passer aucun labo si tu veux
qu'il ne finance à ce que
physiologiquement gilles rien n'explique
qu'un jeune puisse permette de lutter
contre le cancer la seule chose qu'on
essaye de faire avec des malades qui
sont sous chimiothérapie et qui ont un
cancer c'est de dire que peut-être qu'en
limitant un petit peu la ration
alimentaire quotidienne
on va pouvoir épuisé un petit peu les
cellules cancéreuses mais on ne peut pas
passer je peux pas laisser passer un
discours qui dit je viens des
témoignages de gens qui ont été sauvés
parfois d'accord arrêtons avec le
complot de la faculté vous rendez compte
que la faculté refuserait parce que les
laboratoires ne pourrait pas vendre des
médicaments avait ça nous fait passer
pour des gens qui ne sont intéressés que
par le pognon ou qui ne sont plus que de
vendre des amours pas du tout oui je
l'aimé on l'aimé les études sont muettes
par les médecins par les laboratoires
icsa venir et les cancérologues il
s'agissait de juillet dans les airs le
cancer et on le fait pas parce que ça
nous fait que les candidats déclarés les
conflits d'intérêts des gens qui font
des études je vais vous citer juste un
cas si vous me permettez le docteur
autour warburg en 1931 il a reçu le prix
nobel de médecine pour avoir prouvé que
le cancer se développe dans un milieu
acide et faible en oxygène qui ne se
développe pas dans un environnement
alcalin et riche en oxygène on n'a pas
parlé de l' équilibre acido basique de
toute cette alimentation céréales viande
sucre alcool qui est acide donc tout ce
qui est en fait alcalin c'est des
végétaux c'est l'eau et c'est des fruits
si on suit votre raisonnement ça
voudrait dire qu'il ne faut rien manger
d'acide pas du tout à manger de jus de
citron un cancer etc le jus d'agrumes
citron est passé mais raison sur une
chose il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
mange parce que y'en a marre de manger
des pesticides il y en a marre de manger
des perturbateurs endocriniens mais de
là à aller
jusqu'à dire que des témoignages
prouvent quand nous faisons une cure de
jeunes on a guéri un cancer jeudi 16 oct
face d'un discours qui peut être entendu
par tout le monde oui il faut manger
sainement un discours et je vous traite
pas de charlatans qui frôle le
charlatanisme et chez les gens qui ont
un cancer mais aux derniers temps de
charles à tort je voulais que je vous
dis il ne ne traitait pas de charles
atteint je viens de vous dire je veux
dire par là y voyais à pierre marie
martin qui a beaucoup plus d'expérience
que vous sans vous manquez de respect
l'ombre c'est un professeur émérite qui
m'a donné mission de porter son message
mais quand on sait les rôles og un
cancérologue sur toute la commune oui il
il a pas l'air si elle veut dire que
cela veut dire que tous les
cancérologues se sont ligués contre son
discours parce qu'il va pas dans le sens
de la faculté de l'avarié en plein match
je suis déçu comme on obtient cet
argument non il faudrait un musulman
ressorti avant janvier le président
jonathan je vous ai dit que je ne parle
pas de vous là je dis que quand on peut
on se base que sur des témoignages et
qui a rien de scientifique derrière tout
ça à ce moment là et qu'on dit que les
choeurs de jeunes ebit le cancer on
bascule dans le charlatanisme michel
c'est vrai que quand moi je dis à mes
tous libres que je me soigne le foie et
du chardon marie du desmodium et que
j'étais là ils se foutent de ma gueule
mais c'est très bon mais il n'y a pas de
problème mais faites le si vous sentez
bien les gens qui mangent sans gluten en
pensant que ça va améliorer leur santé
alors qu' il n'y a aucune preuve
scientifique que le sans gluten soit
meilleure pour la santé
si vous vous sentez mieux sans gluten
mais manger sans gluten il faut et à 0
encore ya zéro la zéro x ça sera mon
enfant
lio il faut écouter son corps
[Applaudissements]
merci voilà c'est tout seul l'italien
votre taux du samedi avec michel
oui
mais non
david
gill
aussi à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à
chasser
la semaine prochaine à
19h05 et d'ici là demain à 22h45 pour
revoir les missions ou sur ce point fr
salut les terriens
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux